it was important to meet in person so
there can be no mistake about or
misrepresentations
about what i wanted to communicate i did
what i came to do
it was substantive it was concrete
and it took place in an atmosphere that
was geared toward achieving
results american president joe biden and
russian president vladimir putin have
held their first much ballyhoot summit
meeting in geneva
and what's the story of that summit well
it's really two stories
the first is a story of the atmospherics
of their meeting which clearly were
positive
surprisingly so in fact the second is
the story of the substance of their
meeting
where it's not at all clear that things
were quite as positive
first the atmospherics it was striking
how both leaders emerged describing
their meeting in positive terms
president putin called president biden
an experienced and professional leader
and even had good words to say about the
advice mr biden once got from his mother
he said essentially joe biden is a man
of good moral character
it shows the extent of his moral values
and that's all quite attractive and what
i think is on the whole
we spoke the same language that was
striking given that president biden at
one point recently said he agreed that
president putin could fairly be
described as a killer
and that he said once he didn't see a
soul inside him it also wasn't clear how
the putin biden personal relationship
might suffer
in comparison to the admiration the
russian leaders seemed to feel for the
previous american president
donald trump on the biden side the u.s
president said the conversation was
direct in matter of fact
lacking in emotion and he meant that in
a good way and devoid of threats
he said he succeeded in his main goal
which was to be sure president putin
knew where he was coming from
when he expressed criticism of russian
action i told president putin my agenda
is not against russia or anyone else
it's for the american people these good
atmospherics extended to include an
agreement to return american and russian
ambassadors to each other's capitals
after an absence of several months amid
rising tensions
and the two leaders agreed their
governments would discuss a prisoner
exchange that could return some
americans
that president biden says are being
wrongly imprisoned in russia
on substance though the outcome seemed
more mixed the two leaders agreed to set
up a working group on cyber attacks
but president putin defiantly denied a
russian role in cyber attacks
and in recent ransomware cases despite
ample evidence some of them do emanate
from russia
he even suggested more cyber attacks
come from the u.s than from russia
raising the question of how far that
working group can get
most of the cyber attacks in the world
are carried out
from the cyber realm of the united
states
in second place is canada afterwards
latin american countries and then comes
great britain russia is not on the list
meanwhile president biden said the
russian leader knows the u.s has
considerable cyber power of its own
and can use it in response to further
attacks
the two men agreed to start a bilateral
dialogue on strategic stability
probably including arms control but
without a lot of specifics and there's a
long road to travel there
president putin threw human rights
questions back at the u.s by blaming
dissident alexia navalny for his own
arrest
this person knew that he was breaching
the laws effective in russia
he should have noted that as a person
who was convicted two times
and pretending his problems with
political opponents at home were somehow
comparable
to the problem the u.s had when a mob
attacked the u.s capitol on january 6.
president biden for his part pledged he
will continue to raise human rights in
russia
human rights is going to always be on
the table i told them
it's not about just going after russia
when they violate human rights
it's about who we are there were some
good words about working towards similar
goals on afghanistan on iran's nuclear
program
and on humanitarian aid to syria but
again no specifics and a long ways to go
to close the gap
between rhetoric and reality the bottom
line president biden acknowledged what
is usually the case with these meetings
the real concrete results can't be known
immediately but will take months or even
years to determine
let's see what happens you know as that
old
expression goes the proof of the
pudding's in the eating we're going to
know
shortly